-Sadie,
thank you for coming back.
-Of course.
-And thanks for being my partner
in charades.
-Yeah, no, we killed it.
-We crushed it, yeah.
-Yeah.
-Last time you were on the show,
we talked about --
I don't know if remember this --
you talked about playing Annie.
-Yes.
-And I go --
We didn't have the video
to show, but now we do.
-Oh. It's my lucky day.
[ Light laughter ]
-So here's 9-year-old Sadie Sink
as Annie performing "Tomorrow."
-[ Chuckling ] Oh.
-♪ Tomorrow, tomorrow ♪
♪ I love ya ♪
♪ Tomorrow ♪
♪ You're always a day ♪
♪ Away ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-What?!
That's what I'm talking about!
Get up! Come on, Sadie!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Let's get out of here!
♪ Away ♪
Come on!
[ Cheers and applause continue ]
-Oh, my God. Thank you. Oh.
-You've got some pipes there.
-Oh.
-I mean, that's 9-years-old.
-Had just turned 9, yeah.
-And as
a very performing family?
I just met your brother
backstage.
-Yes.
-Is he musical, as well?
So, we did musical theater,
like, all throughout
our childhood,
and we'd, like,
put on musicals and everything.
-Like, where?
Like, in the house?
-Yeah, like, in the house, we'd
do our own at-home production,
which is, like,
normal for theater kids.
[ Audience cheers ]
What's not normal
is just continuing that behavior
at, like, an inappropriate age.
-[ Chuckling ] Yeah.
Like, you've done it recently?
-Like, I'm very embarrassed,
but yes.
But to be fair,
it was during quarantine.
The movie "Cats"
had just come out.
[ Laughter ]
We were all losing our minds,
and so naturally, like,
you know, we were like,
"Okay,
we have to do a home production
of 'Cats' the musical."
[ Laughter ]
But it was great.
It was high camp, lots of fun.
-Yeah, and who was
the audience for this?
-Like, my parents
and my other two brothers,
and we FaceTimed
my grandparents in for it.
[ Laughter ]
I was probably 18 years old.
Like, there's no excuse for it.
-No excuse for it.
-I lost my mind.
-I love that -- at home.
Why not? It's fantastic.
Before we get to "The Whale"
and how great you were
in "The Whale,"
I haven't seen you since
"Stranger Things," Season 4,
and man, oh, man,
you were just unbelievable.
-Oh, thank you.
-It was fantastic.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.
-Cliffhanger.
-Yeah.
-What do you hope for
for Max in Season 5?
-I mean, I would like to --
[ Sighs ]
I'd like to see her awake.
-Mm-hmm.
-I want to know if I have to
get back in the body cast.
I would like for that chapter
to be closed,
but, you know...
-Yeah, it didn't seem --
That's not the most fun part
of the show.
-No.
-But, honestly, you know,
just lie down.
It's kind of an easy job.
-Yeah, I guess so.
-But we'll see.
I have no clue.
-And has the Kate Bush song
"Running Up That Hill"
gonna be like --
has that been your theme song
for the last year?
-It has.
-Yeah.
-Does it follow you around?
-It does.
I was in -- most recently,
I was in, like, Berlin,
in, like, a very tiny café.
It was just me and my friend --
we're the only people there.
And then, of course, like,
the song starts playing,
and everyone in the restaurant
is kind of like --
all the servers are like,
"Oh. What's she gonna do?"
[ Laughter ]
-Like, "Is she gonna
start levitating?
What's happening?"
-No, like, that's my cue to go.
-Yeah, it's like, "Yeah,
we got to get out of here."
Yeah.
I was in a club once --
this was back in the day
when I went to clubs.
-Oh. Okay.
-Gosh. Whew!
Back -- "We used to have things
called clubs."
[ Laughter ]
"Every young kid was there.
Oh, eh, oh."
But I went to this club,
and Axl Rose was there.
And I love Axl Rose.
And he was sitting there,
and they started playing
"Sweet Child o' Mine."
And he just stood up slowly,
and he goes...
[ Laughter ]
-Oh.
He didn't want it.
[ Laughter ]
-They should've turned it
right off.
-So that should be my move
next time.
-That's your move.
You go -- Yeah.
♪ Running up that hill ♪
-Stop.
-No, no. No more, no.
-Cut it. No.
-Let's talk about "The Whale."
-Yeah.
-Congrats.
You're getting rave reviews.
You're nominated for
a Critics' Choice Award.
Congratulations.
It's a big deal.
-Thank you. Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Chuckles ]
-You are --
It's powerful. It is powerful.
It is powerful.
What a performance --
both of you guys.
Did you know
that you were gonna get it
when you auditioned for this?
-Honestly, I thought
I kind of butchered it
because I had to do
the audition over Zoom
with Darren Aronofsky,
the director,
and then Brendan Fraser,
who played my dad in it.
And it was, like,
the final scene of the movie --
-No!
-If anyone's seen it --
it's, like,
a very, very intense scene.
-That was the audition?
-Yes, that, and then
the first scene.
But, like, to do it over Zoom,
kind of trying to, like...
-It's one
of the most emotional --
-...connect with each other --
It was --
So, I, like -- I hung up,
and I was like,
"Oh, I'm never going to see
these people again."
[ Laughter ]
"That's it."
-Yeah, you're like,
"Alright, come on, bro.
Let's do 'Cats' one more time."
-Yeah, I know, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Like, "Back to 'Cats.'"
-"It's getting a sequel.
'Cats' is getting a sequel."
[ Laughter ]
But then -- well, you got it,
and you crushed it.
Have you been getting calls
and texts from everybody
saying how good you are?
-Yes, I have,
but I'm kind of going through,
like, a --
like, a phone issue right now.
Because, like, my phone broke,
and I don't back it up,
and I don't really know
what the cloud is or anything.
So I lost all my contacts.
So people are sending
really sweet messages,
but I just don't know
who they are.
And sometimes I can use, like,
context clues
and piece things together.
-Like, what do you mean?
Like, somebody will...
-Like, Noah Schnapp,
for example --
he texted me the other day.
-Yeah.
-And he always, like,
sends my name first,
just like, "Sadie."
And I was like, "Oh, okay."
-That's Noah.
-Alright, so you're like,
"Thank you, Noah.
I appreciate it.
You're awesome.
What's up, bud?"
-But everyone else,
I have no clue,
so I've just been giving --
-They're like, "Great job."
And you're like...
-"Thank you!"
And just trying to gather, like,
context clues as you go along.
-So, if anyone's gotten
like a --
kind of a dud of a response
from Sadie --
-Yeah, honestly, like,
I'm really glad
that we're talking about this
'cause it's been horrible.
And if any of my friends
are watching it, like,
just send your name
with a text message.
-Just send your name, saying,
"Sadie, checking in again,
this is my name."
-I'm sorry. Yeah.
-Yeah, yeah, and we're good.
Can we set up what "The Whale"
is about for everyone?
-Yeah, so, "The Whale"
is about a man named Charlie
who is a reclusive
English teacher.
And he lost the love
of his life.
And ever since he died,
he kind of has been spiraling
into this deep depression,
has been self-medicating
with food.
And the movie
is kind of set during
what is likely
the last week of his life.
So he attempts to reconnect
with his daughter,
who he had left when
she was around 10 years old.
-Well done.
-And that is the movie.
-Wow.
-Yeah.
-That was a great job.
I want to show a clip.
Here's Sadie Sink
in "The Whale."
Look at this.
-You don't have to be angry
at the whole world.
[ Grunts ]
You can just be angry at me.
-Okay.
You know what?
You can't throw me away
like I'm a piece of garbage
and then suddenly just want to
be my dad eight years later!
You left me for your boyfriend.
-[ Sighs ]
It's that simple.
And if you've been telling
yourself anything different,
then you're lying to yourself.
But you know what?
I'm glad.
I'm -- I'm glad
because you taught me
something very important --
people are [bleep].
Most people learn that
way too late.
You -- You taught me that
when I was 8.
Thank you for that.
[ Sniffles ]
-Oh, my gosh.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well done.
-Thank you.
-Congratulations.
-Sadie, you're an actor
and part of your craft
is making all kinds of sounds
and, you know, for the things...
-Sure.
-...so I thought it'd be fun
for us to make some sounds
right now.
It is time
for the Mimic Challenge.
Here we go.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-♪ Mimic Challenge ♪
♪ Mimic, mimic ♪
♪ Challenge, yeah ♪
-Now, how it works is we're
going to take turns
making noises
with different objects, okay?
And the other person has
to immediately match
that sound
as precisely as they can.
Sound okay? Don't look.
Are you ready?
I will make
the first noise for you.
Here we go. Ready?
-Oh.
-Okay.
Sadie, make --
make this sound.
I don't know if I can do this.
-Mm-hmm.
[ Laughter ]
-Can I do this?
Pbbbbbbbt!
[ Laughter ]
-Khhhhhhh!
-Wow! That's not bad.
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ Ding ]
[ Rimshot ]
That's pretty good.
-Yeah.
-Alright, now,
this is my turn to mimic.
-Okay.
-This is this.
-Oh.
Alright, Jimmy.
-Mm-hmm.
-Make this sound
[ Mooing ]
[ Laughter ]
One more time?
-It's a lot longer
than you'd think.
[ Mooing ]
[ Laughter ]
Hurrrrrrrrrrrrr!
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Yeah.
That's like on pitch.
[ Rimshot ]
-Not bad. On pitch?
-Yeah.
Look at you.
-Alright.
[ Chuckles ]
Sadie...
-Oh. No. [ Laughs ]
Make this sound.
[ Chipmunk squeaking ]
[ Laughter ]
-Whah whah whah whah whah whah
whah whah whah whah.
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ Rimshot ]
It's kind of --
You know, it sounds like a cat.
I was ready for that.
-Oh? Good, yeah.
-Yeah, mm-hmm.
-That was perfect
and also on pitch.
Alright, this one.
Alright, let me see
if I can get this one.
-Oh.
-Hm.
Okay.
[ Honk ]
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
[ Honk honk ]
Alright.
Give it to me one more time.
[ Honk ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Braying ]
Huahhh!
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Rimshot ]
-Yes! Yes.
[ Ding ]
-[ Brays ] Huahh! It's, like,
a little breathy.
-Hunnh! That was great.
-It was a little breathy.
-Okay.
-Alright. Alright.
How about this?
This is a text message.
-Oh.
[ Cellphone bloops ]
-Oooh-errr!
Oooh-errr!
-[ Laughs ]
[ Ding ]
-Oooh-errr!
-Alright. Is this -- This is --
-Oh. I have -- Okay.
-Spreading butter on toast?
-Oh. Alright, Jimmy.
Make this sound.
Maybe it will catch -- Yeah.
[ Butter knife scraping ]
[ Light laughter ]
[ Scraping echoes ]
-No, I'm sorry.
-That's cheating.
-I'm sorry. No, no, no.
You can't do that.
You want more?
-Yeah, I want to hear it.
-You want more?
[ Butter knife scraping ]
-Khhrrrr! Khhrrrr! Khhrrrr!
-Oh. Oh, yes.
[ Ding ]
Yes.
[ Applause ]
-Was is it too --
-Very nice.
-Was it so realistic?
-It was so good.
-[ Laughs ]
-Whoa! Whoa!
-Oh, my gosh.
I am so embarrassed.
Okay.
-Great. Two minutes.
This is the --
-Take the toast.
-Thank you very much.
Yes, I got the toast.
This is the last round here.
This one is for you.
Here we go.
[ Netflix tone plays ]
-♪ Da-dunnnn ♪
-♪ Whaaaaa ♪
[ Ding ]
-That's it right there!
That's how the pros do it!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Sadie Sink!
[ Cheers and applause continue ]
"The Whale" is in theaters now.
We'll be right back
with a performance from Dayglow.
Stick around.
[ Cheers and applause ]